good even welcome to Washington I'm Bret
Baier breaking tonight the historic
process of impeachment collides with the
21st century phenomena of social media
to produce a big moment at today's
second public hearing aimed at removing
a president as the ousted former
ambassador of Ukraine told of her
disappointment over being fired
President Trump tweeted in real-time
that everywhere Marie Jovanovic went
quote turned bad Democrats immediately
derided the president for witness
intimidation a charge he rejects
Republicans questioned Jovanovic if she
had any first-hand information about the
main allegation of quid pro quo now
called bribery by the Democrats she
answered that she did not
but the president's tweet handed the
Democrats a gift during that hearing
today we have Fox team coverage John
Roberts at the White House with the
president taking matters into his own
hands and fingers 280 characters at a
time we start off though with chief
congressional correspondent Mike Emanuel
on Capitol Hill with a very full and
interesting day good evening Mike Bret
good evening to you president Trump was
not on Capitol Hill for today's hearing
but his use of Twitter in an attack put
the president in the middle of the
action
a presidential tweet during ambassador
Murray ivanovich's testimony rocked
today's hearing
l read part of one of his tweets
everywhere murray ivanovitch went turned
bad she started off in somalia how did
that go
president Trump questioned Jovanovic his
record suggesting places she served our
disaster everywhere Murray Ivanovich
went turned bad she started off in
Somalia how did that go then fast
forward to Ukraine where the new
Ukrainian president spoke unfavorably
about her and my second phone call with
him it is a u.s. president's absolute
right to appoint ambassadors and then
you Ivanovich reacted to the attack in
real time I can't speak to what the
president is trying to do but I think
the effect is to be intimidating House
Intelligence Committee Chairman Adam
Schiff quickly labeled it quote witness
intimidation and another word has
emerged in the Democratic lexicon what
is the president has admitted to and
says it's perfect I said it's perfectly
wrong it's bribery Fox News has
confirmed the d-triple-c has been
condemned
doing focus groups in key house
battlegrounds which found the term
bribery the most damning description of
the president's conduct over quid pro
quo or extortion we're not here to talk
about tweets Republican sources
privately acknowledged the Trump tweet
was damning to their side and for the
most part GOP lawmakers did not attack
Evanovich whose credibility directing
most of their fire at shifts handling of
the process our indulge is more out with
you a long time ago mister Djamel
republicans also declined to agree with
the president's decision to recall you
voinovich from her ukraine post which
she claimed was due to a campaign of
disinformation from corrupt ukrainian
interests we have a new administration
in ukraine that didn't have the same
confidence in this ambassador Illinois
Democrat Congressman Mike Quigley mocked
Republicans who suggested because he
Ivanovich ended up teaching at
Georgetown University everything worked
out well it's not the end of a hallmark
movie it's the end of a really bad
reality TV show brought to you by
someone who knows a lot about that when
it was over the witness drew applause
and then lawmakers went behind closed
doors to question embassy staffer David
Holmes based on new evidence Holmes
reportedly overheard a cell phone
conversation between ambassador to the
EU Gordon Sunland and President Trump
when ambassador Bill Taylor says the
president was focused on the
investigations that sets the stage for
next week with eight witnesses expected
to testify in public including
ambassador sunland on Wednesday Rep Mike
Emanuel live on the hill Mike thank you